الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
[Silence]
الله
اشهد
ال الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول الله
[Silence]
اشهد
ان
محمد
رسول
الله حي على الصلا
[Silence]
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلا
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستهديه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا انه من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن
يضلل فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه
وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونصح
للامه وكشف به الغم وكشف الله به الغمه
فصلى الله وسلم وبارك عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث
منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا
سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله
ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما اما بعد فان
اصدق الحديث كتاب الله وخير الهدي هدي
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وشر الامور
محدثات
وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله
في النار ثم اما
بعد الله
[Silence]
الله محمد صلى الله عليه
وس
الله
الله الله
‏he should bear and do not die except as
muslim also says what
means you
mankind fe your lord who created you
from soul and from
it and from
‏over
[Silence]
‏indeed the
spe
الله
gu
محم عليه
وسلم ى الله عليه
وسلم my and
sday something that each and every human
being pur and
every
even animals pursue the same
thing and this is
happiness to be happy in this
life and what makes a person happy
‏happ
life
life for all
the
however happ
‏ay and aous
life having aent house having a
luxurious car and having
properties some other people think that
happ
in being
famous and being
recognized some think
‏other people think that
happin
all and carn says happiness is not about
who you are what you have done where you
are it's about what you think of
it but let us ask ourselves this
question did the people who have all
‏bring them happiness
by
ask of and
women people take
as
i god god they call
‏happ
say people
are
trou fam people they
things not find
happ things
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى isam
‏and the peace of
mind and living free of
fear
con my brs and
sisters the means of happ the religious
isic
‏have spoken about he considered that to
be the paradise of this
life one of the schs of isam
said there is par life that whoever does
not enter it will not enter the paradise
of
the the paradise of this life lies in
closeness eyes
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
iss امامن تيميه رحمه
الله my par
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران ومن يطع الله والرسول فاولئك
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فاولئك مع الذين انعم
الله عليهم من النبيين والصديقين والشهداء
والصالحين
وحسن اولئك
رفيق الله
[Silence]
‏all having fai in
الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران من عمل
صالحا من ذكر او انثى وهو
مؤمن فلنحيينه حياه
طيبه ولنجزينهم اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا
[Silence]
يعملون الله سبحانه وتالى
‏life a
life got in الله سبحانى fai in
الله and you need nure and feed that fai
and that belief by doing righteous
deeds and the reason my dear brothers
and sisters why this the faith in allah
and the righteous deeds bring
happiness and
‏con and
and because the believer who
dos have stands toal
with
have
foring pleasant matters and deing with
matters joyful
things blessings from الله سبحانه وتالى
‏s
t الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى not overy about them not using
them الله سبحانه
وتالى سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران واذ تاذن
ربكم لان شكرتم لازيدنكم
ولان كفرتم ان عذابي لشديد
[Silence]
‏my mys
sisters beli knows how to re things and
also الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
‏sece
cans
that
life الله سبحانه
وتالى وبشر
الصبرين الذين اذا اصابتهم مصيبه قالوا
انا لله و ال
راعون اولئك عليهم صلوات من ربهم ورحمه
واولئك هم
المدون اللهما يوفى الصابرون اجرهم بغير
حب
10 times 700 times
more صلى الله عليه
وسلم عجبا لامر المؤمن ان امره كله له خير
ان اصابته سراء شكر فكان خيرا
وان اصابته ضراء صبر فكان خيرا له وليس
ذلك لاحد الا للمؤمن
[Silence]
اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي
و الحمد لله رب العالمين والعاقبه للمتقين
ولا عدوان الا على الظالمين نعوذ بالله من
شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات اعمالنا من يهده
الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صلى الله عليه
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
[Silence]
صلى الله علسلم
ح ‏so it's very important to not to lose
this
re so one of the means of
helping attaining happiness is helping
people helping others it brings you
happiness and a lot of people wr about
this a lot of
contemporary
people say a lot of things about helping
others how this brings how one of them
says to che yourself up
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
اعتكاف
مسجد رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم س
صنائع المعروف تقي مصارع السو
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وس
‏always
look those who are below you in
the don't look at those who are you
those who have more than you have don't
look at
themuse what happens is when you look at
them you think
you الله سبحانه
وتالى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
حديث انظروا الى من هو دونكم ولا تنظروا
الى من هو فوقكم فانه اجدر بكم الا تزدروا
نعمه ربكم
عليكم صل علسلم are below
not
more
not الله سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله عليه وسلم ‏us not think
about and not conc ourselves about the
future not over the and not havey about
the future focus on the work of
to do something
beneficial whether this is matter
matter قران
صلى الله عليه
وسلم اللهم اني اعوذ بك من الهم
والحزن الله
الهم ان
الحزن صلى الله عليه
وسلم احرص على ما ينفعك واستعن بالله ولا
تعجز
فك شيء فلا تقل لو اني فعلت كذا لكان كذا
وكذا ولكن قل قدر الله وما شاء
فعل الله
[Silence]
ق الله وما شاء
فعل الله
‏you know something
be
seek الا ان
يش سبحانه وتالى
‏number two step
number is do not fall short do not be
negligent you know that you got to study
in order to to have good results in your
s test or whatever project that you have
to do you need to be prepared for it do
that take the causes take the
means youve done all
that you have you been eer to do is
benefici you put your trust in allah
‏him and supp but
things صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم alles
قدر الله وما شاء فعل الله
‏con
[Silence]
think الله سبحان الله سبحان الله سبحان
الله الحمدلله الحمد لله الحمد لله الله
اكبر الله اكبر لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
سبحان الله وبحمده سبحان الله
العظيم الله سبحانه
وتعالى الا بذكر الله الذين امنوا وتطمئن
قلوبهم بذكر الله الا بذكر الله تطمئن
القلوب
[Silence]
الله صل
علس رسول الله صلى عل وسم وجعلت قره عيني
في الصلاه
[Silence]
ناها
ياال
ياانه
اللهانه اللهانه
الله سبحانه
وتعالى ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار اللهم اعز
الاسلام وانصر المسلمين في مشارق الارض
ومغاربها يا رب العالمين اللهم اعزنا ولا
تذلنا واكرمنا ولا تهنا وانصرنا ولا تنصر
علينا وامكر لنا ولا تمكر علينا اللهم من
ارادنا والاسلام والمسلمين بسوء فرد كيده
في نحره واجعل تدميره في تدبيره وخذه اخذ
عزيز مقتدر يا رب العالمين اللهم اشف مرضى
المسلمين وارحم موتى المسلمين اللهم فرج
كرب
المكروبين واد الدين عن المدينين يا رب
العالمين ربنا اغفر لنا ولاخواننا الذين
سبقونا بال ايمان ولا تجعل في قلوبنا غلا
للذين امنوا ربنا انك رؤوف رحيم وصلى الله
وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين واقم
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد
ان لا لا اله الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان محمد رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه حي على الفلاح حي
على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووا استقيموا يرحمكم الله سووا الصف
فان تسويه الصف من تمام الصلاه ريت لاين
بليز
استووا الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا تن
الا ما شاء الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
سنسر
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم لا يموت مت فيها ولا يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين
والعصر ان
الانسان لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات وتواصوا بالحق
وتواصوا
بالصبر الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ب s
‏we still do havex don back don on